يعتقد الناس في الذكاء الاصطناعي السائد أن ذلك كان
سخيفًا تمامًا ، يبدو
سخيفًا بعض الشيء ، إنه سخيف بعض الشيء ولكنه
يعمل
[موسيقى]
ما رأيك في فرص الذكاء الاصطناعي في
القضاء على الإنسانية ، هل يمكننا وضع
رقم على أنه في مكان ما بين
نسبة الحليب  و 100
أعتقد أنه
إذا كنا عقلانيين ،
فسنحاول تطويره حتى
لا يحدث ذلك ، ولكن ما يقلقني هو
المواطنون السياسيون نحن في مكان
يحتاج فيه الجميع إلى أن يكون عاقلًا
[موسيقى]
ماذا  هل مخاوفك
هي أن
الأمريكيين يرغبون في استبدال
جنودهم بالاستقلال الذاتي بواسطة جنود منظمة العفو الدولية وهم
يحاولون العمل من أجل ذلك
وما هو الدليل الذي تراه هناك ، فأنا مدرج
في قائمة بريدية
من وزارة الدفاع الأمريكية.  لست
متأكدا من أنهم يعرفون أنني رشحت هذا